all right real quick I don't want to
spend a lot of time on cat turd this
isn't really a program where cat turd is
a big thing but Donald Trump hit an
absolute Rock Bottom Rock Bottom new low
posting cat turd pulls to truth social
truth essential I managed to get through
that mostly without laughing yes Donald
Trump in an act of desperation to show
how well he is doing against Ron
DeSantis in the Republican primary over
the weekend posted new poll just out and
when you look closely you realize that
the poll is from the cat
the poll is from the the cat turd uh
Twitter account this is a um an account
that pushes right-wing nonsense it isn't
a poll it's quite literally just like a
Twitter survey where a couple hundred
thousand followers of cat turd voted and
Trump did have have 69 percent of the
vote compared to Ron desantis's 24. and
I don't know that there's really that
much commentary to do here other than
Trump is posting cat turd in in the
middle of the night is not typically the
or actually this one was in the
afternoon to be completely clear it's
not typically what you would expect from
a former president cat turd is not big
among Obama captured notably not big
among George W bush but Trump posting
cat turd and it's all getting very sad
and very very uh tragic if uh if I'm
totally upfront with you all right let's
take a quick break we're going to get to
book Banning we're going to get to the
regrowth of uh of toes through prayer
and lots of other important things after
this very short break